Just because I'm
a girl, I should not
be denied my right
to be in school.
An advocate is someone
who sees an injustice
and doesn't ignore it,
but wants to take action.
I wanted to just go to
school without the worry
that anyone would
kidnap me or stop me.
That was my dream.
On the 9th of October,
2012, the Taliban
shot me on the left
side of my forehead.
They shot my friends too.
They thought that the
bullet would silence us,
but they failed.
I was receiving so much
support from around the world,
and I realized that I
could use it to speak out
for girls everywhere who do
not have access to education
right now.
This class is for
anyone who wants
to create a better,
fairer world for everyone.
You will learn the
four-stage advocacy cycle.
I will also be talking
to two amazing advocates,
Amika George, who convinced
the UK government to provide
free sanitary
products in school;
and Lewis Iwu, who works with
leaders to develop strategies
for their activism.
Storytelling and
authenticity are
very important as part of a
strong message for your cause.
There are moments
when you get nervous,
and you get a bit anxious.
Those things are
common, they are normal.
Hope and optimism are
the most important.
That is what keeps you going.
No matter where you
live in the world,
how old you are,
where you come from,
you can become a change maker.
You can become an activist
in your community.
I am Malala, and
this is MasterClass.